[Music]
hey you guys time once again for a
flickers of fear book review
and on this installment we're going to
be talking about probably one of the
most infamous notorious
uh horror novels
of the past
i don't even know the past few decades i
guess ever since it came out it
originally came out in 1989
and if you know anything about horror
fiction and you know if you've seen any
people's lists of like most disturbing
books ever written
and things of that nature pretty much
this is on every one of them that i've
seen
and uh i will say rightfully so this is
the girl next door
by jack ketchum now as i said this
originally came out in 1989
and i will say this is like
i talked about this on my tbr because
this is a book that i've read at least
once i might have written i might have
read it uh twice in the past
and i really wanted to do a reread of it
mostly because it's so
iconic and it's so you know it's one
that a lot of people are just kind of
like
you know it's like i said it's a very
very disturbing and it comes up on a lot
of people's lists so i definitely wanted
to
discuss it that said if you haven't read
it
i'm kind of like i'm reluctant to
recommend it necessarily because even
though i think it's a brilliant book
it's brilliantly written it really makes
you
i mean if horror is meant to make you
feel disturbed and disgusted and just
like questioning
the [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] are
humans even about it's like then this
book succeeds probably better than any
other book i've ever read
but i will say that
this is so [ __ ] up that you can't
un-read it
so if you're somebody that's gonna be
that knows that they're gonna be really
upset
by the [ __ ] that happens in this
because it's very very
it's not exploitative but he doesn't
really shy away from describing some
pretty horrible [ __ ] that happens
so
uh if that's gonna bother you i would
recommend not reading it because
it's gonna stay with you like forever
and
i kind of i've watched like some other
people's reviews of this too and like a
lot of people were like you know i felt
like i had to read it at least once but
a lot of people like yeah i'm never
gonna read that ever again so i don't
know if there's something that matter
with me that i've read it like three
times now
but there's something about it that it's
like even though it will just make you
angry and depressed and just you know
what the [ __ ] like
it will just make you weep for humanity
you know
it's one of those kind of books so it's
not a fun experience so like i said
that's like i can't really recommend it
across the board even though i think
it's a brilliant book and i think that
if you know what you're getting into
and you think that you
i'm just this is gonna sound douchey but
it's like if you think that you can
handle it and like i said no shame if
you can't because it's like i
i read this and i'm almost sorry i read
it but in some ways i'm kind of not
because
if you didn't know
this is it's a fictional novel but it's
loosely based on a real case that
happened and the real case is if
anything even worse than the horrific
[ __ ] that happened in the book
so
in a way i like that he fictionalized it
not a lot but to an extent that you
could
a little bit sort of
i don't know if i'd say distance
yourself from the actual story but
because this is something that actually
happened to somebody to a child it's it
has a lot to say about you know not just
the monstrosity of like what monsters
humans can be even humans that are
supposedly
normal you know and how like one
person's
uh you know savagery can infect others
so there's that element to it too but it
also kind of goes into
people who stand by and do nothing even
though they could do something and it
also kind of goes into what was going on
in the united states in the in the 1950s
like with all the kind of authoritarian
repressive type of [ __ ] and like how
children were treated um you know how
they were kind of just supposed to be
not so much seen and not heard but you
know they they were under the absolute
authority of adults and
i feel like child abuse spousal abuse
things like that weren't things that
were really talked about to a great
extent and i think that at the time it
was kind of like
you know it wasn't that unusual uh you
know for kids to get smacked around or
for you know wives to get smacked around
so
the fact that that abuse this horrific
could take place just under everyone's
noses essentially with a lot of people
you know a lot of kids in the
neighborhood participating
um just kind of goes to show how
you know up to a point it was kind of
like an accepted thing that happened so
no one really thought
that much about it and it seemed it's
really sad because it seemed like at
some point someone could have intervened
and no one really did and then by the
time someone intervened it was too late
so as i said this originally came out in
1989
it's based on the real case of sylvia
lykins the murder of sylvia lykins which
has a wikipedia page and like i said if
you really want to ruin your day you can
go and read that and it's [ __ ]
horrifying
so the real case sylvia lykins was a 16
year old girl
and she and her
younger sister whose name was jenny were
taken in by
i guess a friend of their parents their
parents were carnival workers so they
were gone like you know several months
out of the year and they knew this woman
uh i believe her name was gertrude
banicheski if i'm pronouncing that
correctly she offered for money to look
after them for a few months i believe
it's from like august to november
something like that while the parents
were away like at work
now what ended up happening was that
i guess after a month or two uh the
maintenance checks stopped coming
gertrude got
pissed off about it and decided for
whatever reason
that she was going to start essentially
torturing
uh sylvia and to a lesser extent her
sister and she also got all of her
children and several of the neighborhood
kids involved in the torture it was like
a [ __ ] up lord of the flies situation
but in some ways even worse because in
lord of the flies you know these kids
started acting like savages because
there were no adults around to stop them
whereas in this case which jack ketchum
also goes into in this fictionalized
version was that
in this way you had an adult an
authority figure that was
seemingly making this okay which
probably went a long way toward why all
these kids sort of went along with it
and thought that there wasn't really
anything the matter with it even after
they got caught
you know even when they were in court
and things like that they really didn't
seem to see the issue or they didn't
really seem
to feel that bad about it
so it's i mean the real story is a
horrifying horrifying story
this one is fictionalized but it's
loosely based on the real thing
so in the novel
the novel is actually told in the first
person
and it's told from the point of view of
a guy named david now at the beginning
of the book he's kind of just talking
about how he's been like financially
successful in life but you know he's on
his third marriage now and he's having
like all these kind of other like
emotional problems and things like that
and at which point
he decides that he's going to write down
something that happened to him back in
1958 when he was 12 years old um just to
kind of like purge it out of i guess
somehow because he wants everybody to
know so i think it's interesting because
even though the real case took place um
you know the sylvia lykan's murder that
actually took place in indiana in 1965.
jack ketchum actually um throws this
back a few years back to the 50s and he
says there's kind of a long um
sort of author's note in the back of
this particular edition where he's
talking about um you know why he did
that and like you know he kind of talks
about how he came to the story and
things
and he says that you know i wanted to
set it at a time like when i was around
this age and
he doesn't say it outright but like i
said it's kind of implicit and it's
interesting that he said it back in the
50s instead of the mid 60s because of
the
you know the inherent sort of
authoritarian like i said sort of thing
where you know kids just they did what
adults said that was just what you did
back then and so that kind of like feeds
into
this story and like what he wanted to
say about this character so the
character of david we go back and he's
recalling
uh 1958 when he was 12 years old now he
lives on this dead end street his
parents are sort of
they don't go a lot into his parents or
you know their relationship but you can
tell it's very uh distant it's very
broken um the dad has had a lot of uh
affairs and um you know there's some
maybe
implied like maybe a little bit of
spousal abuse in there too
but david doesn't really he he doesn't
really feel that great an attachment to
them
um but there's kind of a thing and i
think the beginning of the book i mean
it takes a while before
the actual like horrific [ __ ] starts
happening
but i like that it's this kind of long
build up it's almost kind of i've seen
it kind of compared to like a stephen
king type story like uh stand by me um
you know or the body as the story is uh
originally called like that kind of
thing where
it's you know it's the 1950s it's the
idyllic american middle class sort of
neighborhood it's this dead-end street
all the kids on the street are you know
roughly the same age they all kind of
know each other they all hang out
together you know they're all listening
to elvis records they're all doing this
and i think he got i mean since this was
also the same era that he grew up that
jack ketchum grew up in so he seems to
have a real handle on
you know what was going on at the time
what kids were like at the time you know
what the pop culture was like at the
time so i think that really lends this
just such a great sense of authenticity
which in turn
sort of feeds into like the the tragedy
of what ends up happening
so he lives in this house next door
is a single mother named ruth chandler
and her three sons now in real life
gertrude had i believe seven children
and they weren't all boys some of them
were girls as well and the girls also
participated in the torture but in this
one it's all boys
so ruth
i guess like back in the even though she
was a single mom and people kind of
looked at scants like even david's
parents are just kind of like you know
they're they're civil to her but they
don't really want to associate
because she'd apparently been married a
few times like her husband had taken off
on her and various other things and
she's kind of bitter about it but in a
lot of ways david hangs out at her house
a lot with the sons i mean it's friends
with the older sons because the mom is
very permissive in the sense that she
just lets the kids hang out over there
you know you can come in you don't have
to knock or anything like that she lets
them smoke cigarettes she you know
sneaks them a beer every now and then
she lets them do things you know the
neighborhood kids do things that their
parents wouldn't necessarily be happy
about them doing so a lot of them like
to hang out over there and david even
says near the beginning that he's like
you know when he was 12 years old he
thought she was i don't know if she
necessarily said she was cool but it's
like you know
he liked to hang out over there because
he
felt like he could be himself at her
house in a way that he couldn't around
his parents
so
shortly after um
you know this whole kind of establishing
scene
you have the arrival of a 14 year old
girl named meg
and her sister whose name is susan
now
like i said in real life the two sisters
their parents were still alive but the
parents were working and they just like
left them with a family friend
essentially
uh in the book megan susan's parents are
killed in a car accident in which both
sisters are wounded although meg only
has some scars on her arms susan is
pretty much she can walk but only with
crutches
uh and she has braces on her legs so um
yes so she was pretty messed up in the
accident and as i said both of their
parents were killed
at which point they are sent to live
with ruth chandler who is sort of like
an aunt or like a distant relative so
she is kind of like related to them so i
guess like the state puts
you know puts uh the sisters in the care
of ruth because she's the only living
relative of the parents
so david first meets meg in sort of this
idyllic you know situation where he's
out at this brook where they all used to
play and he's catching crayfish or
whatever and she comes and she's a
couple years older she's 14 he's 12. but
you know she's really good at catching
crayfish and he's impressed and he talks
about how pretty she is so it's almost
kind of like they're setting it up at
first like meg is like his first crush i
guess like he thinks she's really pretty
and he thinks she's really cool and then
he finds out that it's like she's just
moved in with ruth and the boys next
door and so um he's very excited about
that she's like oh i'll be seeing her
all the time and you know we can all
hang out together and it'll be really
awesome
so for a time it kind of goes like that
and there's like some scenes near the
beginning like i said which
are really good because knowing how this
story goes it's like the more that you
get these little scenes of them just
like kind of sweet like he takes her on
the um the ferris wheel at the carnival
and they're kind of like talking and you
know just like sweet scenes like that
this kind of like knowing how the story
goes it just makes it all the more
heartbreaking because
you just know that this is like the last
time that this girl is gonna be happy
and it's just i don't know this this
book like i said is this is a
soul-crushing book okay so i'm just
telling you that right now and i know
that some people would not want to read
this and i do not blame them at all
because like i said if you read this and
then you know that it's based on a real
case it's just gonna it's gonna bum you
out it's just gonna make you feel like
and i know that some people don't wanna
read something that makes them feel like
that and like i said i don't blame them
whatsoever but i will say that i think
the reason that i've read this book two
or three times now at this point is just
because yes it's soul crushing but it's
also very
powerful you know and i kind of like
this exploration of this moral gray area
particularly in the character of david
who
as i said sort of as you know things go
on in the book like he knows what's
happening but
he doesn't really do anything and having
things from his point of view
is really interesting because you can
kind of like see what like what's going
on at his head and stuff like that and
you're like well you know if i was a kid
during this time period what would i
have done would i have told somebody
what i've told a cop what i've told my
parents you know would anything have
happened
and in a way like you can kind of feel
sorry for him because as i said in that
cultural context you know even if he had
told you know how helpful would it have
been because you know there were some
things that transpire in the book where
people did like telecop or something
like that but nothing really got done
because they're just kind of like oh you
know she probably had it coming or
something like that because like i said
people smacked kids around back then no
one really thought that much about it so
everyone probably just thought she was
making a big deal out of nothing but
i like the exploration in this of
his complicity and his guilt about
standing by even though david
doesn't participate in the abuse
directly
um he does watch it
and he does admit that sometimes he felt
you know aroused by it or excited by the
prospect that you know this is allowed
now
even though initially he had had a crush
on her and actually liked her as a
person and was like sympathetic
empathetic even but then as time goes on
it's almost kind of like he has these
little bursts of
resentment maybe she did do something to
deserve this maybe you know it's it
can't be wrong there's an adult is
perpetrating it you know an adult that i
like is perpetrating it so it can't be
wrong she must have done something to
bring it on so like i said this is like
some pretty dark it's very grim it's
very heavy you know but it does explore
these kind of
questions of
you know if you see something like this
going on you know what is your
responsibility to like try to stop it
and he doesn't try to stop it not really
like until the end
so
as it goes on like i said at first
ruth decides that she doesn't
particularly like meg now they don't
really go into because you're not seeing
this from the character of ruth's point
of view
but
you do kind of get a sense that ruth is
kind of like
she seems to me like a self-hating
woman like i guess because maybe and
like i said this is an implication and
this may not have been jack ketchum's
intent
but i kind of feel like maybe
in her upbringing
she was kind of taught a particular
thing about women because she says
things about other women oh women are
just [ __ ] you know that's all they're
good for is just to get you know [ __ ]
over and used and then left behind and
so i kind of feel like the implication
being that maybe she was taught that and
maybe
her life experiences
have sort of um
solidified that for her so it's almost
kind of like she's lashing out at other
women and particularly at meg because
meg seems like a little pretty girl
who's kind of on the cusp of womanhood
so ruth maybe sees her as
not threatening necessarily but sees her
as sort of emblematic of
everything that she hates and everything
that she couldn't have uh because now
she's older she has she's been saddled
with three kids so she says you know
she's had two or three husbands that
have left her she's been [ __ ] over
like pretty much her whole life and so
she
resents meg because meg represents
um you know burgeoning womanhood or
someone who still has her whole entire
life ahead of her and so she decides
that she's gonna punish her that way
there's also um it's not even an
implication it's actually said outright
that
ruth
gets a sexual charge out of torturing
meg and also uh it comes out later that
she's also sexually abusing susan the
you know the little crippled girl so
that comes out as well even though susan
doesn't get as much abuse she still gets
a lot of abuse as well so there's that
uh and she's also used as a bargaining
chip for you know if meg won't do
what uh ruth or the other kids want her
to do then she'll say oh we're gonna
take it out on susan and susan can't run
away because she can hardly walk
so as i said it kind of goes to the
point where at first it's just kind of
like teasing or you know but very
mean-spirited teasing toward uh meg
where it's like you know calling her a
slot um you know saying she's fat uh
that type of stuff you know and then
like kind of you doing things like
tickling her and then like grabbing your
boob or like you know
[ __ ] like that which like i said it's
bad but
at first it doesn't really seem like
anything egregious um at least you know
considering how far it gets later
now as it goes on and on
the abuse kind of gets worse and worse
and as i said at some point meg does
actually report it to a cop but the cop
doesn't really do much of anything about
it um thinking like i said that it's a
family matter uh ruth is your mom now
and i'm sure
you know you are maybe a troublemaker
and you deserve to get smacked or
whatever you know she's trying to keep
you in line so it was that kind of thing
so they didn't really investigate it to
any great degree so
as time goes on it just gets worse and
worse until
they essentially ruth and her sons chain
meg in the basement
and won't let her come up you know the
various forms of torture and as i said
this is based on a true story uh and a
lot of he did change at some things but
not that much
so most of the stuff
that happens to meg in this book
actually also happened to sylvia likens
uh in real life so
that's cheerful i'm sure at first she's
just kind of roped to the ceiling um and
they kind of have her standing on books
and then they'll take the books away so
it's like you know the strain and
everything they won't really give her
any water they won't really give her any
food uh you know she gets very
dehydrated they won't let her take a
bath
and then they start doing things more
like
sexual type things where they you know
they'll cut her clothes off they start
cutting her they start burning her with
cigarettes at one point uh they feed her
dog [ __ ] it's this this kind and like i
said that actually uh did happen you
know they piss on her face it's just
like all these horrible horrible things
and then like as it goes on it really
gets into some horrifying which i don't
really want to get too much into
but you know bodily mutilation uh rape
other things of that nature
and uh it's not just ruth at this point
kind of participating it's also her
three sons
and it's also some of the neighborhood
kids because now it's become sort of
like it almost becomes sort of like a
thing where you know oh let's all go
over to the chandler house and go down
to the basement and just and just do
whatever we want to this girl that they
have
chained there because like i said
because an adult is supervising it even
though she's clearly insane uh that
gives them license to pretty much do
whatever they want to her
um you know at this point she's just
like a thing to know like a plaything
now i will note too that even before
meg gets there like even before meg
moves to that um to the house
neighborhood kids did actually have
something that they called the game
where they would essentially it just
started out as sort of like a tag sort
of game but you'd get to the end and if
you got captured they would like tie you
to a tree and then once the girls
started playing they would tie the girl
to the tree they'd take her clothes off
they would like ask her like all these
you know creepy questions they would
touch her in sexual ways and stuff but
that was with the girls
sort of consent like that like they were
kind of all so so there was kind of like
a precedent because as it goes on when
they had meg down in the basement you
know the chandler boys actually told
their mom about this hey we play this
game out in the woods with with some of
the girls and you know we like to do it
to each other so it's like let's do this
to her because
you know she's just this thing that we
can like use however they want to use
her
so yeah so like i said um you can
probably imagine like where this is
going the outcome of the book is kind of
the same uh in the sense of what happens
to meg in the sense of what happens to
susan uh you know the sisters but the
outcome of the book is actually a little
bit more satisfying than what happened
in real life i will say that i don't
really want to spoil it so like i said
if you are
if you really really don't want to read
about horrific horrific child abuse
portrayed in a very realistic and quite
graphic way uh you know children doing
other abuse on other children while
adults are like supervising or looking
on and also participating um if that
does not sound like something that you
want to read then please do not read
this because
it's one of those books that will
definitely stick with you for a very
long time and will make you kind of
question your own
i don't know like question your own like
what would you have done if you were in
david's situation because like i said
david for a long time even though he
knows what's going on over there and
even though he never as i said directly
participates in the abuse because he
still to a small extent still sees her
as a person
but he does kind of wrestle with the
fact that he was excited by it and that
he also kind of is still wrestling with
the fact that all of this guilt that he
had for not really doing anything and
really he did do something in the end
but by that time it was kind of too late
um and the damage had already been done
and um you know and and like i said you
can question
how much you know how effective would
him intervening have been i mean he was
only a 12 year old kid but i mean he
does kind of try to be the hero at the
end he does kind of do some things but
it's you know as i said it's too little
too late but just the fact that he
wasn't able to help her and that he
in some ways was complicit in what
happened to her by not
telling anyone about it you know is kind
of like [ __ ] him up so that to me
was
one of was one of the most powerful
things about this story is that
and that's why i'm i like that he wrote
it
um from the point of view of a neighbor
who was there who wasn't participating
but he was watching it and didn't take
any responsibility for it and was almost
kind of like trying to
justify like oh it's okay because i
didn't i didn't hurt her and no one
would have listened to me anyway i was
just a little kid you know so he kept
coming up with all these excuses for why
he didn't tell anybody but in the end he
didn't tell anybody and um
you know it ended up pretty much as bad
as it could end up and he's never really
gotten over it in the sense of the book
now they did actually make a movie
adaptation of this and i believe it was
2007.
uh so the one that's 2007 i think
blanche baker was in it that the movie
is pretty good uh it sticks pretty close
to the book it's obviously there was
some stuff they couldn't that was in the
book that they couldn't really show but
it's still pretty a pretty faithful
adaptation and then they made a movie
called an american crime which actually
isn't based on the book but it's
actually based on the real case it's
based on the sylvia lykins uh case which
had uh ellen now elliott paige which i
had i don't think i've seen it but i've
heard it was very good i didn't mind the
movie adaptation of the book but like i
said it's not the same as reading it and
i think that it sort of like lessened
its impact a little bit because i mean
they had to have an older girl playing
meg um because in the book she's only 14
and obviously you don't really want to
make a movie with a 14 year old girl
having all the [ __ ] happens to her what
happens in this book so they had to have
an actress that was older that was like
over 18
and it's pretty evident that she's over
18. i mean she doesn't i'm not saying
she looks like
like way older or anything she does
still look young but she's
obviously like much older than the
character is supposed to be um and i
understand why they did that there's
really no way around it i mean obviously
you don't want to see a real 14 year old
girl in that role but it's still i think
it's still lessened the impact somewhat
but the movie is still good and still i
don't know if i want to say it's worth
watching because it's also pretty
heart-wrenching uh the book is worse i
will say that but the movie is pretty
hard to watch also and like i said i've
read some reviews of this and some
people said look i just watched the
movie and there's no [ __ ] way that
i'm reading the book because the movie
was [ __ ] bad enough which like i said
in the book is worse now i will say too
that
i mean i've liked i've read most of jack
ketchum's other stuff he sadly passed
away a couple years back i think it was
in 2018 and all of his stuff is great i
mean he is known as much like richard
layman although i think jack ketchum is
a better writer uh than richard layman
just in general but all his stuff is
very graphic you know is very brutal but
that said his writing is just so there's
something just really really compelling
about his writing style it's very
it's very to the point
he doesn't uh it's not flowery at all
it's not and in this book in particular
i think that really goes a long way
toward
selling not only like making this a book
that you want to put down because it's
so [ __ ] horrible what's happening but
also you can't put it down because his
writing is just so
you know it's just so so powerful just
these kind of short sentences and just
the way that he just lays everything out
like straight
straightforwardly and everything like
that just makes it even more horrible
because
you know this is what happened and he's
just like putting it in your face so you
can't really
get away from her you can't really like
turn away from it so i think in a way
like i said i've read pretty much all of
his books i think off-season is also
great which is about cannibals um you
know it wasn't based on our true story
it's more like a regular horror but his
whole thing is he's fascinated by
human monsters more than supernatural
monsters he wants to
delve into
you know the darkest
side of the human psyche and sort of
just bring it up and show it to you and
say this this is what you know this is
what your fellow humans are capable of
given you know the situation at hand and
i think that can be the most disturbing
kind of horror so i mean easily easily
this is one of the most disturbing books
i've ever read and from looking at the
reviews most people agree
that
i mean if you are really not into
disturbing real [ __ ] because like i said
this is it's fictionalized but not that
much uh so if you really don't want
if you really don't want to like you
know confront this [ __ ] story about
what happened to this poor [ __ ] child
and her sister too to a slightly lesser
extent it's just i mean like i said it's
not a fun time it's not an enjoyable
book that's why i'm saying that it's
like really hard for me to recommend it
to somebody because i don't want to like
recommend it to somebody and be like
thanks i'm like [ __ ] traumatized for
life now
but
if you're in the right if you know what
you're getting into and
you just want to kind of read a thing
about
you know where you just go into the
darkest [ __ ] corners
of human savagery
and read about something like that and
people's reaction to it then i think
it's actually a brilliant piece of
writing and it's actually one of my
favorite books i know it's a [ __ ] up
thing to say because this is a very
[ __ ] up book
but
the violence in it though is not
exploitative it's not the same as you
know watching like a fun gory horror
movie it's like you know watching you
know people's heads get chopped off and
stuff like that i mean that's just
you know that's yes that really happens
and stuff like that but in horror
fiction that's usually like fantasy it's
kind of like just you know it's fun it's
like a fantasy fulfillment type of thing
this one is a whole other
uh this book is a whole other kettle of
fish it's really not it's not written
the violence is not written in there to
titillate anyone it's not put in there
to excite anyone it's put in there to
disgust you
at how
horrible and how horrific and how savage
humans can be so so that said like i
said it's not a fun read it's very grim
but
i really do it's it really is one of my
favorite books of all time and that's
why i wanted to do a review of it
even though
you know as i said i just can't
recommend it across the board because
it's just a horrific book but i i love
it in a weird way but it's one that you
really want to like space out
if you're gonna read it more than once i
would like put along because it's really
one that it kind of like wears you out
emotionally
i will say that too but yeah so
if you think like i said if you think
that like you're not it's not gonna like
[ __ ] give you trauma for life which
like i said if you do think that that's
totally fine i'm not i'm not saying
anything but yeah this is uh jack
ketchum the girl next door this is the
cover i bought this one back in the
early 2000s i want to say there was one
that came out i think the original
paperback i just wanted to mention this
because i've seen another edition of
this which i think was like the older
edition because this one's not that old
but
one of the original edition of this
which i think was from warner
publications or whatever it was kind of
one of those 80s paperback originals
where they had these really like cheesy
ass covers this one had a cover
of a skeleton
in a cheer like a 50s cheerleader outfit
like with the saddle shoes and the
pom-poms and everything which i thought
was like so [ __ ] bizarre because if
you saw that cover and then you read the
book you'd be like what the [ __ ] what
the cup the cover doesn't have anything
to do with anything and the cover just
really kind of like i don't usually get
offended by like cover or anything but
that i was just like that totally like
cheapened the whole [ __ ] book that
looked like some kind of cheesy
you know like some cheesy 80s slasher
type of artwork which i wouldn't it
wouldn't bother me if it was that kind
of book but it's totally totally not so
i don't know like what whoever designed
that cover i don't know what the [ __ ]
they were thinking but every time i see
it i'm just kind of like i just shake my
[ __ ] head i'm like what the hell like
a [ __ ]
cheerleading skeleton what the [ __ ] does
it have to do with like vicious and
horrible child abuse that's based on a
true crime i have no idea but i just
if anybody knows like why like
who made that [ __ ] executive decision
uh i'd really like to know because what
the hell man what were you smoking i
don't know but anyway
yeah so uh
jack ketchum the girl next door i will
like honestly i i really love jack
ketchum's work um like i said it's it's
brutal it's vicious you know if you're
in the mood for it if you know what to
expect then his writing is actually very
powerful so i would recommend it you
know in that regard
but otherwise you know
buyer beware i guess i'm gonna say but
yeah that'll do it for this tomes of
terror and i will see you guys on the
next one
bye